keine ahnung ob es genauso ist aber bei
mir ist es in den letzten monaten so
dass wenn ich in meiner youtube app auf
dem handy gehe das mit komplett
bescheuerte videos empfohlen werden ich
mein ich gehe jetzt einfach mal in die
elbe rhein und issel gepackt was ist
dass annie mit sound men
ich habe mir auf jeden fall die letzten
wochen einige videos zusammen gesammelt
die mit dort immer so vorgeschlagen
werden
und die schauen wir uns jetzt heute
gemeinsam an das hier ist das erste
video mit dem titel ja ich habe keine
ahnung was hier abgeht erhält dieser
ente glaube ich ist es ein ei entgegen
die ente lehnt das ganze ab kann die
rente auch reden jetzt ja klar ich halte
enden auch immer als haustiere also das
ist wirklich so ein schwachsinn der mir
die letzten wochen etwa auf youtube
angezeigt wird müsste ich gucke mir
eigentlich nur fußball und auto videos
an und jetzt kriege so endet also ich
meine die sind süße keine frage die sich
die sind schon die sind unfassbar
juli kann man enden als haustiere hat
aber gut ich würde sagen wir machen
weiter mit dem nächsten video und zwar
heißt es der isi es battle pikachu
evermann also das leichteste der
leichteste kampf den die katzen gewonnen
hat ich habe keine ahnung
ja so was fehlt mir dann empfohlen von
diesen typen handelt das nächste video
ich habe auch wieder keine ahnung was
das geht ja mal ich bin luca
[Musik]
das ist die wahrheit durch
ich weiß ich das richtig geht
er geht mit seiner ganz bei wohnort
einkaufen geht doch nicht mit dem tier
auch rein oder ein paar sekunden später
also wir jetzt wirklich auch mit dem
george anscheinend da rein oder
einkaufen wurde allein auch die tatsache
dass er in service york jacken dings
hier um hat wahrscheinlich ist eine
ganzen behinderten holen war aber
unterhaltsam das video das jetzt das
nächste video und zwar heißt es zeit ist
emily aufs gas also ein fahrrad fast
checken die einfach wieder ab drei
millionen aufrufe dieses video hier hat
irgendwie wieder so ein chinesischen
tippe ich ganz leer ab der vogel 8 kg
jetzt in der knopf auch noch selbst
damit oder was alter bisher immer wenn
ich so was so eine andere youtuber laden
so richtig qualitativ hochwertige
gramzow nicht reagiere auf einen vogel
der herbert wolle die content das hier
ist das nächste rico mental
youtube-video ich hab keine ahnung was
sie abgibt das ist shrek
das kis das ist das ist shrek shrek das
ja auch immer das gemacht hat alter das
ist richtig gute schnitt arbeit gewesen
also klar es wird natürlich auch
supported davon dass überall hier grüner
boden ist und er den wahrscheinlich als
green screen genutzt hat um das ganze zu
gehen und dort das ist ja glaub ich
eigentlich ein hund und hat er dann
schräg drauf gepackt haben junge wieder
alle herzlich willkommen zu meinen
youtube recommendations wird festes
turtle aber ich habe auch keinen plan
was hier abgeht der typ filmt einfach
irgendeine echt enorme riesige
schildkröte und filmt die von sehr nahm
arbeiten liebe schritte vom mikro auf
jeden fall der in der woche ich habe
auch wieder keine ahnung worum es hier
gerade geht der typ geht einfach aus
seinem haus raus beziehungsweise in
seinen garten aus dem haus kam und
überall sind irgendwie baby enden die
wohl denken dass er der vater sei
der typ geht weiter und die enden die
gab er geht
[Musik]
ich kann's noch mal sagen was dem titel
stehen aber ward was will mir youtube
sagen mit solchen videos dieses video
heißt big ist firework es ok war das
sieht jetzt okay das schon ein bisschen
wie viel langeweile
haben
er testet wirklich jedes einzelne wasser
da und durch abwasser ist wasser vor der
markt das ganze vor allem fast neun
minuten lang so viel langeweile hätte
ich gerne gab an der stelle wo ich das
heute wieder ist allerdings auch beenden
meine lieben freunde den letzten monaten
ist einfach aufgefallen dass youtube mit
kompletten bullshit an videos empfohlen
hat ich hab dir einfach mal ein bisschen
gesammelt und habe mir gedacht hey das
wäre doch lustig wenn wir einfach mal
zusammen darauf reagieren würden wenn es
euch gefallen hat anlass um gegen einen
daumen hoch unter dem video hier da habt
ihr bock auf einen zweiten teil reagiert
auf youtube recommendations dann
schreibt uns in den kommentaren
abonniert main kanal falls sie noch kein
teil der luke zu sein und jetzt kommt
der sound raum
[Musik]